the wrong shoe Theory may have
single-handedly solved our fashion
problems a concept dubbed by stylist
Alison Bornstein is one of those styling
tricks that one scene cannot be unseen
and these outfits just prove that it
works wearing your new favorite tailored
suit swap those heels for a trainer
tempted to try out the super comfy
pajama Trend stick on a heeled sandal
oversized cargo pants pair them with a
skinny pointed pump a super lightweight
semi-share dress bulky biker boots would
work perfectly see where we're going
with this essentially the more wrong it
feels the more right it probably looks
it's all about wearing an unexpected
shoe a shoe that would typically be the
very last one you'd pick for any
particular outfit